okay so even on x-axis symmetry y-axis
symmetry origin symmetry what do all
these terms mean and how can we tell if
a function has a particular type of
symmetry or whether it's even or odd
that's what we're going to talk about in
this video the first thing I want to
show you though is that say you take
like a sample point like X comma Y if
you reflect this over the y axis what
happens well you know it's the mirror
image but you can see that now the x
value is the opposite right but the Y
value stays the same so when we're
testing to see if an equation is
symmetric about the y axis all we do is
we go to the equation we put negative x
okay in for X and we keep Y the same and
if we get the original equation back
when we simplify that tells us that it
has y-axis symmetry now if we're
reflecting over the x axis notice how
the x coordinate stays the same but the
y coordinate changes signs right so that
is how we test for x axis symmetry we
would keep the X the same but we replace
Y with negative Y when we simplify that
equation if we get the original equation
back that tells us that it's symmetric
about the x-axis and then if you were to
rotate 180 degrees about the origin okay
you would end up here negative x
negative Y and that's what we do we
replace X with negative X Y with
negative Y in the original equation it
formally simplify if we get the original
equation back that tells us that it has
origin symmetry now switching gears a
little bit here talking about even-odd
what you do is you put negative x in
place of x so this is just a different
notation if you get the original
function back then that tells you that
the function has that it's even and what
even means is that it's it's symmetric
about the y axis okay it's just another
way of saying y-axis symmetry we call it
even if we put negative x into our
function and we get the original
function back but it's multiplied by
negative 1 see it's the opposite of f of
X then that tells us that the function
is odd and what it means is that it's a
rotation 180 degrees about the origin ok
so let's do an example we're gonna go
through three examples and I'll show you
how this works so first of all let's do
the even odd what I'm going to do is I'm
going to put negative
okay in forex so wherever I see X I'm
gonna replace it with negative X
whenever I do a substitution I like to
put it in parenthesis because you want
to treat it like a group so a negative
times a negative times a negative times
a negative four times right a negative
to an even power is going to be a
positive same thing here a negative
times a negative that's gonna be a
positive x squared then times this
negative minus three now notice this
equation is the same as this equation so
what does that tell us it tells us that
it is an even function meaning if we
were to graph this it would be a
reflection over the y-axis so that's it
it either has to be even or odd it can't
be both when you talk about the symmetry
though it could have x axis symmetry y
axis symmetry origin symmetry but let's
do the symmetry test to the same
function here instead of f of X f of X
represents Y so I'm just gonna rewrite
this as y equals x to the fourth minus x
squared minus three here what we're
going to do now is we're just going to
go through the three symmetry tests so
I'm gonna replace X with X and then
replace Y with negative Y so if I do
that and I could multiply through now by
a negative one so that's gonna be y
equals negative x to the fourth plus x
squared plus three does this look like
the original equation no so that means
it doesn't have symmetry about the x
axis let's go to the number two here so
we're gonna start back with our original
equation we're gonna replace X with
negative X Y with positive Y so if we do
that and remember negative to an even
power is positive negative and power is
positive and you can see here we're
getting back the you know original
equation so that tells us that it does
have y-axis symmetry now we already knew
that because of the even odd tests we
found out it was even which means the
same as y-axis symmetry but I'm just
showing you that the different test and
then the third one we would replace Y
and X with negative Y negative x so I'm
replacing Y with negative Y replacing X
with negative x and we're gonna see if
it gives us back the original equation
now after doing this a few times you're
going to be able to just look at these
equations
and you're gonna be able to tell which
type of symmetry it has but in this case
if I multiply through by negative one
that's going to make this positive Y
negative X to the fourth positive x
squared positive three does it look the
same as original equation here no so
that means it's not symmetric about the
origin
it was just the y-axis symmetry or when
we talked about even I we talked about
as being even jus we have f of X equals
x over x squared plus two so let's go to
the even odd test now remember it has to
be either even or odd it can't be both
whereas with the symmetry test it could
be one of them two of them all three of
them okay you just have to check so for
the even odd we're gonna replace
wherever we see X we're gonna replace
that with a negative ax so I've got
negative x over negative x squared plus
two so when we simplify we've got
negative x negative x times negative x
is positive x squared plus two and when
we look at this if i factor out a
negative one
what do I get I get x over x squared
plus two so this represents our original
equation right you can see they match
but it's multiplied by negative one so
what does that tell us it tells us that
it's odd see it's the opposite of f of X
or f of X times negative one which means
that if it's odd it's a rotation about
the origin K 180 degrees so just
remember odd and origin go together okay
and even and y-axis symmetry those go
together and x-axis doesn't have like it
doesn't match up with any of those so
let's now let's kind of switch gears and
go back to the symmetry test so we're
working with this equation here we're
gonna go ahead and put X and negative Y
in so what we're gonna do f of X you can
think of that as like Y so we have y
equals x over x squared plus two and
we're going to replace X with X Y with
negative Y so we have negative y equals
x over x squared plus two if we multiply
both sides by negative one that's going
to give us negative x over x squared
plus two does it look like the original
equation no so that means it doesn't
have x axis symmetry so let's go ahead
for y axis symmetry now so we're going
to do is we're going to replace
so negative XY with positive Y so if we
do that we get negative x over negative
x squared plus two and if we simplify
that gives us a negative x over x
squared plus two does that match the
original equation no so that tells us
it's not y-axis symmetry and the last
one we're gonna make them both negative
okay so if we do that we have Y negative
y equals negative x over a negative x
squared plus two we simplify we get
negative x this is x squared plus two
and if we multiply both sides by
negative one these both become positive
now you see it matches the original
equation so that tells us that that's
this is origin symmetry so it's a
rotation about the origin 180 degrees of
course we already knew that when we did
the even and odd test it came out odd
which is origin symmetry so now remember
they can be more than one but let's look
at one more example of x equals x times
the square root of x squared plus one so
let's start with the even odd tests so
first thing we do is we substitute in
negative x right so wherever we see
actually replacing with negative x and
over here we have negative x squared
plus one so negative two and even power
we know is positive okay because the
negative tends to negative and here we
have negative x now when we look at this
you can see that here's our original
equation right original function but
it's multiplied by negative one so what
does that tell us it's this bottom one
here it's odd it's a rotation 180
degrees about the origin and of course
once we know that it's odd we also know
that it has origin symmetry but I'll
show you those tests as well so let's go
back to the symmetry test so let's start
with x-axis symmetry so f of X we can
think of as like Y so we have y equals x
square root of x squared plus one but
we're going to do is we replace X with
an X Y with negative Y okay so if we do
that we can multiply both sides by
negative one so this would give us y
equals negative x times the square root
of x squared plus one notice this whole
thing is like one group it's all
multiplied together but see how its
multiplied by negative
because we multiply the left and right
sides does this look like the original
equation no so that means it doesn't
have x-axis symmetry okay let's go to
number two so here what we're going to
do is we're going to place X with
negative x and Y with positive Y so we
have y equals let's see negative X
square root of negative x squared plus
one so if we simplify this gives us x
squared plus one but again does this
look like the original equation no
because that negative in front so it
doesn't have a y-axis symmetry and then
the last one we're gonna replace X with
negative X Y with negative Y and if we
do that let's see what we get
let's see so here are negative x squared
gives us x squared plus one times
negative x equals negative y mmm excuse
me if we multiply both sides by negative
one those negatives are going to cancel
and you can see this matches our
original equation which tells us that it
has origin symmetry but of course we
knew that because when we did the even
odd test that's odd normally when you do
these problems your teacher will either
be talking about symmetry or about even
odd sometimes we'll be doing them
together so that's how you work with
these if you're new to the channel I
encourage you to subscribe this channel
is all about helping you to raise your
grade pass your class and go on to
pursue your dreams and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful I
look forward to seeing the future videos
I'll talk to you soon